So let's begin
modeling this problem
as a linear
optimization problem.
In terms of the framework that
we have seen in the lectures,
our objective is to maximize
the revenue to Google.
Our decision is for each
advertiser and each query
to decide the number of times
that advertiser's ad will
be displayed for that query.
Our constraints
are of two types.
Our first constraint is that
the average amount paid by each
advertiser, based on the
number of times Google displays
their ad for each query, cannot
exceed the budget of that
advertiser.
Our second constraint is that
the total number of ads we
display for a query
cannot exceed our estimate
of the number of requests
that we expect to see for that
query.
Let's quickly review
our problem data.
We have the average
price per display
for each advertiser
and each query.
We have the budget
of each advertiser.
And we have estimates
of the number
of requests for each query.
So let's now think
about how to model
all the pieces of our problem.
First, how should we define
our decision variables?
Well, we should define them for
each advertiser and each query.
So for example, one of
our decision variables
will be x_A1.
x_A1 is the number
of times we will
display AT&T's ad for query 1.
Similarly, we can
define x_A2 and x_A3.
These are the numbers of times
that we will display AT&T's ad
for queries 2 and
3, respectively.
Now, of course, we have
three different advertisers,
so we will have variables
x_T1, x_T2, and x_T3.
These variables represent
the number of times
that we display T-Mobile's
ad for queries 1, 2,
and 3, respectively.
And, of course, our last
advertiser's Verizon.
So we will have variables
x_V1, x_V2, and x_V3, which
are the numbers of
times that we display
Verizon's ad for queries
1, 2, and 3, respectively.
Now, how do we compute
the revenue to Google,
which is our objective?
Well, we know the average
price per display,
and our decision variables
tell us exactly how many times
we'll display each
ad for each query.
So all we need to do is we
need to multiply each decision
variable with its corresponding
average price per display
and add them all up.
If we did this, we would have
0.5*x_A1 + 0.5*x_A2 + 1.6*x_A3
+ 1*x_T1.
And we can continue this.
And the last term in
our sum will be 5*x_V3.
To get the constraints,
we use a similar process.
For instance, to get
how much AT&T pays,
we multiply the AT&T variables
by their average prices
per display and add them up.
So we'd get 0.5*x_A1
+ 0.5*x_A2 + 1.6*x_A3.
Now, one of our constraints,
as you will recall,
is that this cannot exceed
AT&T's budget, which is $170.
So our model would have the
constraint 0.5*x_A1 + 0.5*x_A2
+ 1.6*x_A3, is less than 170.
We can repeat this to get the
same kind of budget constraint
for T-Mobile and Verizon.
Now, to get the number
of times query 2 is used,
we add up the decision variables
corresponding to query 2.
So we have x_A2,
the number of times
AT&T is paired with query 2.
We have x_T2, which
is the number of times
T-Mobile is paired
with query 2, and x_V2,
which is the number of times
Verizon is paired with query 2.
Now, one of our constraints
is that this cannot exceed
the estimated number of requests
for query 2, which is 80.
So our model would have the
constraint x_A2 + x_T2 + x_V2
all less than 80.
We can do this for
the other queries.
So we can do this for
query 1 and query 3.
And this is all
that we really need.
So now, let's take this
problem to LibreOffice
and actually solve it.